What is it that gives your life a sense
of meaning and purpose?
Because once you find that,
it puts you in your power place.
See if you know what your life work is.
I encourage you to start working on it.
If you can't do it all at one time,
do just a little bit of it and if you
don't know what it is that you showed up
to do,
if you don't know why you're here,
I encourage you to find out what your
purpose is here.
What is the meaning of your life?
What will be different?
Have you ever asked yourself that
question?
I've done that.
I,
I remember coming from a friend of
mine's funeral and I was reflecting on
how much time I had left and I went for
a walk in the park thinking about this
guy whose life was so promising and I
mean he wasn't an old guy who was quite
young in fact,
and I thought about all of the things
that he said he was going to do and he
never got a chance to do those things.
And I start thinking about my own life
and how much time I had left to do the
things that I would like to do.
And at that time I wasn't sure what my
life purpose was,
what my life's work was.
I wasn't sure about it at that time and
I thought about it quite a lot.
I had some idea,
but I wasn't convinced that I don't
think I felt worthy.
I didn't believe that it could be me to
do this kind of work that I'm doing
right now.
And I say to you that if you began to
take a conscious effort to find out what
it is and you're supposed to do,
I say that it can literally save your
life.
I said that it can literally save your
80 five percent of the American public.
I caught him to recent studies are going
to jobs that they hate working on jobs
that do not challenge them.
They get sick.
Thinking about going.
Because see,
when you go to a job and you already
know how far you can go,
you can already see that proverbial
glass ceiling.
See,
when you're going someplace and you
already know how much you're going to
make,
you already know how far you can go.
You're in a dead end position.
It erodes your self esteem.
It lowers your sense of yourself.
It creates an inner turmoil.
It creates an emptiness in you.
Say That your life is worth finding what
it is that you're supposed to do,
and I'm not saying quit your job.
I'm saying find it to do just a little
bit on just on working at it just a
little bit,
but do find out what your work is and
hold onto it and don't let your dream
go.
Don't let it go.
See,
and here's something else I want you to
begin to look at.
Why is it that most people don't pursue
their dreams that don't do better than
what they're doing?
If they're capable of doing it?
I think that many of us don't go the
next step because we don't know what to
do yet,
and I say that,
that the reason that we don't even
explore the possibility of what to do is
because subconsciously we don't believe
that it can happen for us and we don't
believe that we deserve it.
So here's what I'm suggesting.
How much time do you spend working on
you?
How much time do you spend every day
working on your dream and the last 90
days,
how many books have you read
and the last year,
what new skill or knowledge have you
acquired?
What kind of investment have you made in
you?
So I'm saying that as you begin to look
at where you want to go,
if you want to make it today and things
are changing so fast,
you have to literally run to stand
still.
I'm saying that you've got to make some
conscious effort to begin to work to
develop you.
Here's something else.
Most people are not living their dreams
because of fear.
Ladies and gentlemen,
fear limited vision and lack of self
esteem is what keeps most people doing
things.
They don't want to do.
The same reason that people stay in
relationships where they abuse or
they're unhappy or it's unfulfilling.
They can't see themselves beyond that
relationship.
They can't see themselves enjoying life
without that person.
They think that this has all been.
They can do the same reason that people
get stuck at a certain level in life.
They can't see things being better for
them and they think that this is,
and this is all they deserve.
This is all they've ever seen.
It's been passed onto them and they fade
with this is it for them.
Oh No.
I'll look in what Dr Blanton Smiley
Blanton,
who is a colleague of Dr Norman Vincent
Peale,
what he said about theories that fear is
the most subtle and destructive of all
human diseases.
Ladies and gentlemen,
fear kills dreams.
Fear kills hope.
Fear what people in the hospital fear
can age you.
Fair Ladies and gentlemen can hold you
back from doing something that you know
within yourself that you are capable of
doing,
but it will paralyze you
and it seems like you're in a hypnotic
spell and I asked you a question.
What is the benefit?
What's the benefit of allowing fear to
hold you back?
What's the benefit of giving up on
yourself?
I'm not stepping out on life and taking
life on what is the benefit for you?
What's The plus in that?
So
one of the things I had to ask myself,
so I didn't want to make any mistakes.
I wanted everybody to like me.
I want it to be perfect.
The first time I did something.
It's not gonna happen.
You're gonna.
Make some mistakes.
You're going to hurt some folks,
feel it.
You're going to create some enemies
whenever you decide that you want to
begin to take life on,
you got to ask yourself,
how long am I going to allow this to
hold me back?
I like what Zig Ziglar says.
He said,
fear is false evidence appearing real.
That is the illusion that we create in
our mind.
It is a state of mind that can be
changed,
so let's look at how we can begin to
take some steps to restructure that
fear,
to begin to expand our visions of
ourselves to begin to increase our self
esteem.
Webster said that self esteem means
competence and satisfaction in one self.
Look at your life right now.
Whatever you've done up to this point in
time,
your life is working.
Whatever you have produced it came out
of you as result of the kind of person
that you have become as a result of your
choices,
as a result of your consciousness.
Now you have to ask yourself,
are you satisfied with what you had
produced?
Is this what you want?
Would you like things to be better than
this?
Do you believe that you deserve better
than this?
Aren't you content?
This is it.
You don't have to do everything.
Anything else that you already with Zan
yourself in life and said,
well,
I'm happy I'm not starving like the
people in Calcutta.
Are you allowing yourself to get off the
hook like that or do you believe
somewhere in the back of your mind or in
your heart that there are some other
great work for you to do this,
something else that has me you,
and that's why you are here?
How do we handle this fear factor?
How do we increase our self esteem?
You have to begin to fortify yourself.
How do we do that?
I believe that you have to begin to
consciously monitor your inner
conversation and start talking to
yourself.
Start building yourself up.
Sometimes the only good things you will
hear about you,
other things that you say to you.
I'm saying,
learn to be your own booster.
Start building yourself up.
Start encouraging yourself.
Start saying,
I can do this.
I can make this happen.
When I started thinking about becoming a
speaker,
I said,
yes,
I can do this.
I can make this happen.
When I stopped trying to convince myself
I can be a businessman after flopping
and failing and losing thousands of
dollars and feeling stupid and dumb and
having people take advantage of me
because of what I did know,
I had to talk to myself because people
were saying to me that I was dumb and
somewhere in the back of my mind I was
saying,
you're right.
Look at what I've done.
I had to say,
no,
no.
Hey,
hey.
Come on man.
Get your stuff together.
You can handle this.
You just haven't figured out yet.
It's all right.
This is your training theory.
This is tuition.
You have to pay for what you don't know
you can do this other people have done
it.
Doesn't take an Einstein.
Get you some people that can teach you
some stuff that you don't go get you
some people that have done it
successfully and learn from them.
Take some seminars,
workshop.
Read some books on how to manage your
business,
changed the way you see yourself and
begin to attend to the personal details.
Understand that nobody's gonna take care
of your business better than you,
and when I started changing that kind of
mindset of beating myself up because of
my mistakes,
and start looking at the possibility of
my doing better of my making,
the adjustments that would have enabled
me to do what I want to do successfully,
things began to change.
I say stopped beating up on yourself.
You do do it.
I know you're doing it.
I've done it.
It's a natural inclination for us to put
ourselves down.
See,
we're born negative.
I think in a negative consciousness
because we live in a negative world.
Here's some other things.
Ladies and gentlemen,
begin to guard your mind against
negative programming like turn off the
television.
Don't watch the news so you've got the
God the kinds of things that you put in
your mind.
See,
if you don't program your mind,
your mind will be programmed because
human beings are goal oriented.
That's why we die of broken hearts
early.
That's why we're running through life to
early grades.
We're going through life,
ladies and gentlemen,
and I think that Henry David Thoreau
said that most men live in quiet
desperation.
Most of us go through life running
scared,
so we had created this in our mind is
false evidence appearing real?
We made it real in our minds.
That's why Churchill said,
there's nothing to fear but fear itself,
that's the disruptive monster.
So turn off things that can contribute
to your fear.
Turn a deaf ear to people that all they
can do is talk about how negative things
are because they have bought into the
consciousness of the world.
Start attending workshops,
seminars,
listening to tapes on a daily basis to
begin to recondition your mind,
to retrain your thinking.
Faith comes by what hearing and hearing
and hearing,
listening to things that could empower
you,
that can enable you to create a new
reality for yourself in a new life for
yourself.
You might appear to be strange around
most people you know.
Most people think you're strange.
If you're happy today,
say these people have not found their
purpose in life.
That's why they are grumpy,
but that's why they're miserable.
That's why they're so negative,
they're hurting and they want to hurt
other people.
So start practicing using programs for
your mind,
seminars,
books,
workshops.
Keep a journal.
Record your thoughts,
what's happening with you everyday when
you get up,
have a journal near you.
See,
ladies and gentlemen,
we get three to four thoughts a year
that if we would act on those thoughts,
hey can change I ally.
What I did are you setting on write your
ideas down and then once you get that
idea,
take the lead.
Take the lead out here in the universe.
If you don't take the pledge,
I guarantee you somebody else will take
the plunge.
Go into action,
and ladies and gentlemen,
you will be surprised at how things will
come together.
You'll be surprised.
Now you're going to have some difficult
challenges.
I can tell you that now.
Be aware of that.
Things are not going to work out exactly
right for time.
They will sometimes,
and that's when life is just playing the
game with you.
I
want you to feel good and relaxed,
but ladies and gentlemen,
go into action with your dream and don't
avoid where the fights are.
Get in the midst of the fight.
Get knocked down so you can learn how to
fight so you can hold your position.
Say,
most people don't get out in the arena
of life because they don't want to
fight.
Most people don't get out of there
because they don't want to get knocked
down.
They don't want to be dropped to their
knees,
but say you're going to be dropped.
Whether you on the field or where
they're not just sitting on the
sidelines,
you're going to be dropped,
so at least get dropped with something.
See,
that's not most people are spectators in
life.
You don't want to be a spectator.
You want to get out in the field where
the action is and you will be amazed
after the struggle,
there will be a calm period and it began
to click for you.